Nearly 5 billion years ago, more than 10 million centuries, to form the first single cell, the source of all life, flagellates, the first many-celled aquatic plant.
With the Cambrian period came various new forms of life, medusas, phallobites, ostracoderm, the very first fish.
4 billion years, 40 million centuries passed before there appeared on solid ground the first amphibian, Ichthyostega.
In the succeeding millennia, the various species evolved by means of natural selection.
No sooner had they left the water than reptiles began to colonize the world.
Thecodont, Archaeopteryx, the first primitive bird, has just taken flight.
Wegener's theory states that the Earth, one solid mass up until then, underwent division.
Continents drifted apart.
The secondary period saw the triumph of the dinosaurs, whose descendants include crocodiles, as well as birds.
Then nature seems to have tried her hand at some interesting experiments.
The armored tank model Stegosaurus, 8 meters long, weighing 6 tons, a softy to boot.
A shame that such an impressive physique was run by a walnut-sized brain and a very tiny head.
Fearsome Allosaurus, life is hard on softies.
Our next model is Brontosaurus, 20 meters long, weighing in at 20 tons.
He too has a tiny head, with a brain no bigger than an apple, not quite enough for 20 tons of muscle.
Still, he was tops in his category, a heavyweight.
Even heftier was Diplodocus, at 30 meters, the tallest of the lot.
He was more streamlined, with a tail like a whip and a swan's neck.
And here's the all-round champ, the largest beast ever to have walked the Earth.
Brachiosaurus, 24 meters long, 12 high.
In relation to his size, his brain was the tiniest.
This didn't prevent our lizard with arms from reaching the 50-ton mark.
We have some legendary monsters, Elasmosaurus, not as heavy but still quite presentable at 18 meters.
Could he be the Loch Ness monster?
The fabled dragon, Pteranodon, the largest flying reptile with a wingspan of 8 meters.
Life wasn't easy in those days.
And how about sea surface?
Like Tilosaurus.
Oh, life wasn't easy in those days.
The duck model, Anatosaurus.
Though less adventuresome, this plant eater didn't mind an occasional change of diet.
But, careful, Priceratops doesn't appreciate such interest in his offspring.
Walking Terror, a real monster, the most ferocious of these giants.
The King Tyrannosaurus, 15 by 6 meters, 8 tons, jaws lined with a double set of razor-sharp teeth.
The certain way wasn't easy.
The dinosaurs, having reigned supreme over the Earth for more than 100 million years, at last gave way to small mammals.
Unlike the mastodons, these rodents could adapt to climatic conditions and natural upheavals.
The old of the secondary period gradually faded away.
From its wreckage, a new world emerged.
World-sized tree-living insect eaters may have been the forefathers of the primates.
Those branches would include apes, anthropoids, and hominoids.
Although actual proof of the connection is hard to come by.
Here is a rodent.
Mylodectes, its skull larger, orbits higher.
Egeoptopithecus, skull still higher, the face flatter.
Pliopithecus, already an anthropomorphic ape.
Consul, means, get the food.
You mean nothing left.
It seems that male supremacy was open to question, uh, even then.
One member of the group has, uh, some trouble keeping up.
Natural selection.
At work, he's saying, this is my territory, please leave before I lose my temper.
When food became scarce, they had to leave the forest for the first time and set out into the open country.
Easier from an upright position.
As he straightened up, Proconsul's pelvis became stronger to support his trunk, arms, and head.
His legs grew longer.
Thousands of years went by, and the great anthropomorphic apes evolved.
Caniopithecus, 1 meter 20.
Ramapithecus, 1 meter 30.
Australopithecus africanus. A meter and a half. Australopithecus robustus. Australopithecus evolved becoming more agile. He was taller due to straighter posture. His brain capacity grew from 450 to 660 cubic centimeters. Here's the Old Duvet Gorge in Tanzania in the heart of Africa, where he lived. In his paradise, many species of animals flourished.
Obustus was a vegetarian.
Not that its usefulness had occurred to him yet.
A million years ago, a tribe of Homo habilis, they were carnivorous.
Catch nothing, no, you not eat rats.
Meat, meat, meat, meat, meat, meat, meat.
You're gonna at least try being polite to us when we ask for something to eat, my friend and me.
Hey, hey, hey, over here!
Obustus was hunted to extinction.
Homo habilis now reigned alone.
In time, Homo habilis left the grasslands and wandered over other continents, far from his homeland.
The level of the seas dropped sharply during the glacial periods.
The sea fell to 100 meters below its modern level, forming land bridges that linked the continents.
700,000 years before our time, Pithecanthropus, or Ape Man, more correctly called Homo erectus,
he measured up to 1 meter 60 centimeters.
His brain volume reached 950 cubic centimeters.
They're still quite elementary.
Got it, territory, how does animal belong? Us!
Give us animal, right it, eh? No, you better just bash your head with no tool.
These new inventions aren't quite up to snuff.
No, no, stop, not that, oh!
Ah, well, bravo, you've certainly had success in hunting today, my boys.
Pretty bird I caught.
And me, I caught this one in the bushes.
I believe you're the strong man here, son.
Might I just suggest we pause for one or two moments here before returning home?
Okay, master, you have spoken well, mm-hmm.
Don't you eat that! Anything else but that!
Who listens to old fogies anyway?
All right, let's go on.
Come see how nice it feels.
Right into our cave and we'll be warm. Why waste it here?
The tribe needs food. We must catch great beasts.
More men for that.
The tribe will hunt as a group.
See, meanwhile, me and my hunters will chase down and corral the herd.
It's me, the chief.
That's right.
He who holds the fire is chief.
Not a chance. The chief here is me.
700,000 years ago, time was ripe for man.
It had taken the earth nearly 50 million centuries to set the stage.